it has been two weeks since the supreme
court overruled roe v wade and planned
parenthood v casey in dobbs versus
jackson women's health organization this
is the greatest supreme court decision
in my lifetime maybe the greatest
supreme court decision in the history of
the court well we are all still
celebrating the libs are not celebrating
they're crying they're screaming they're
rending their garments and gnashing
their teeth and we have the definitive
collection of the greatest
tick-tock meltdowns
on the overruling of roe v wade get
angry
how [ __ ] dare the supreme court do
this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you kavanagh [ __ ] you gorsuch for a
lying under oath when you were confirmed
saying that you believed that this was
settled women will die how do i have
less rights than my mother the fact that
you tied religion to your decision is
pathetic you [ __ ] conservatives love
fetuses you love fetuses you are
pro-birth it stops women from dying from
it stops women from having back alley
abortions
most of the time it's a clump of damn
cells cells
cells
so women get to relive their sexual
assaults for life there are children in
the foster care system that you won't
adopt so please tell me how you are
pro-life how
dare you
karma does not forget not on my watch
i'm not persuaded
i don't know about you i'm not persuaded
i felt that was a one-note performance
you believe that this was settled
women will die
it was as though she was trying to seem
angry but i'm not even sure that she's
totally angry
it seemed
forced and pushing as to the content it
was all nonsense it was all the same
sort of shallow talking points it wasn't
even the more interesting abortion
talking points she's saying that the
supreme court decision focused on
religion she obviously
obviously she didn't read the supreme
court decision she's saying that
conservatives don't support pregnant
women and babies after birth that's just
not true conservatives are much more
likely to give to charities to support
crisis pregnancy centers there are 36
couples willing to adopt newborn babies
for every one newborn baby put up for
adoption in the united states it's just
it's just all nonsense one moment she
seems to care for the baby in the other
moment she's saying that women who are
raped now have to look at the reminder
of their rapist meaning that the very
existence of their child was too much of
a burden and so it'd be better to kill
that child and of course rape accounts
for less than one percent of abortion
significantly less than one percent of
abortion so anyway it was a weak
performance the producers put this
compilation together they want me to
pick the very best
they're not sending their best next one
why doesn't the government care if i
live
why don't they care
[Music]
why don't you care about us
that's it that's all you got this is
like the audition for the strasberg
studio
and i don't think this lady's getting in
it's really it's really weak
performances generally i guess this is
what a narcissistic culture does a
culture that tells you just constantly
to be posting on social media he says as
he posts on social media this is what
you know this kind of selfie culture
where you're just always sitting there
and venting your emotions all the time
well eventually your your emotions just
become deadened and you've just got to
you've just got to try to perform it you
push why why i don't think i don't think
so i don't think that would get you cast
in the high school play lady much less
make you a big tick tock star summer is
always busy people are away from home
quite a lot i just got back from a big
trip over to los angeles i think half of
my team is out right now
they all say they're sick they're
probably sitting on a beach somewhere
well when you are away from the home
know that your home is safe with ring
you know about rings video doorbell it's
fabulous
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your doorbell whether you're in the
house at your office on a beach
somewhere well ring has a wonderful
award-winning alarm home security system
ring alarm they've got available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe you can keep an eye on your
your windows and your doors and your
whole physical home well now you can
get ring alarm pro be like me be a pro
gopro
cnet calls ring alarm pro a giant leap
for home security because it allows you
to protect your physical home and your
digital home you spend so much of your
life online protect that router protect
your data protect the whole kit and
caboodle right now i absolutely love a
ring i've given it to friends when they
move into a new house to learn more go
to ring.com
michael mich ael that is ring.com
michael now back to the tick tocks all
the human rights are going to start
falling down
all right lgbtq
plus community we're next on the
chopping block and birth control
and possibly interracial marriage
so pretty much we're going
the only thing that's going to have
rights in this country is
white men and goods
so there is a lot that's confusing in
this video the first thing she says is
that lgbt is in trouble now if there's
one group that is uh not going to have
their lives changed by a ruling to
outlaw abortion or to send abortion back
to the states where they may or may not
outlaw it it would be
homosexuals
at least as of now when two boys come
together and two girls come together
they they do not make a baby this is not
something that they need to worry about
and then what she does this is actually
what makes it kind of interesting is she
gives the argument that the libs give in
their dissent in the dobbs case that
overrules roe v wade forget about
abortion right now forget i don't want
to talk about abortion but this decision
means that they're gonna
change the definition of marriage back
to what it was for all of human history
until like five minutes ago and they're
gonna overrule lawrenceville texas which
finds a constitutional right to
homosexual sodomy somewhere between the
emanations and the numbers and the
invisible link they're going to overrule
griswold which is the case that finds a
constitutional right to condoms again
don't really see that in in the text i
don't think that's what madison was
talking about but hey anyway uh you know
i'm sure you can pass laws and have
condoms or sodomy or whatever you want
to have but it's just it's not in the
constitution they have to distract and
it's even funnier because in the opinion
in the majority opinion of that case of
the dobbs case the court said explicitly
we're not talking about lawrenceville
texas we're not talking about burgerfeld
we're not talking about griswold we're
not talking about gay marriage or
contraception or any of that stuff this
has nothing to do with that clarence
thomas and his concurrence
said actually maybe we should look at
that too but he was the only one who
signed on to it the rest of the court
wouldn't so this tick tock seems to me
so far to be the most serious one
the most organic one and probably the
most confusing one next up i think that
if you can leave the country you should
i think if you're childbearing age
and you can leave the country you should
if you can't we need to rise up we need
to fight you've gotta you've gotta leave
the country if you can't kill your kids
why would you wanna be in america where
are you gonna move to she says if you
right now if you're in america they've
made it harder to get abortions so
you've got to leave the country are you
going to move to
france germany anywhere other than i'm
not joking
china
canada america's hat
or north korea those countries have more
liberal abortion laws than the united
states probably better to stay here and
and better not to kill
your child all right that was the last
video i think i'm gonna have to give the
award to that third woman it was the
most original that first woman i mean i
could record that video
the second one i don't even really
remember but that third one that was she
she opens up the video she says
all the human rights are going away she
seems sincere she's deeply deeply wrong
and i hope she sees this video i hope
she can be illuminated and i
congratulate her on winning the silliest
tick tock meltdown
over the overruling of roe v wade keep
melting down lives and we will keep
celebrating see you next time
women will die